from traveling theater producers to
hip-hop Pioneers to child Brides the
stars of The Fifth Element have had real
life experiences that are just as wild
as Luke bassan's 23rd Century Vision you
can't have a great science fiction
action film without an action star and
that's where Bruce Willis comes in
Willis was tapped to play the lead
Corbin Dallas a retired major in Earth's
Special Forces he stumbles into the blot
when lilu falls into his cab completely
upending his plans for the day you okay
well this was already a well-established
member of the action movie Community
when he was cast having headlined the
Die Hard franchise and dozens of other
films since the 1980s
after wrapping up his work on The Fifth
Element Willis kept his winning streak
going with Armageddon The Sixth Sense
and unbreakable then he returned to the
small screen in 2000 appearing in a
handful of Friends episodes which earned
him his second Emmy Award for
outstanding guest actor in a comedy
series throughout his career he's taken
home numerous accolades including a
Golden Globe People's Choice Awards and
more Willis remained popular throughout
the 2000s and 2010s though many of his
later films were released direct to
video and weren't well received in March
of 2022 Willis's family released a joint
statement on their social media accounts
explaining the action star was retiring
following a diagnosis of aphasia
Willis's Aphasia was diminishing his
cognitive faculties making further work
impossible in February of 2023 Willis's
wife Emma Heming updated fans in her
husband's dementia X explaining that he
had been diagnosed with frontotemporal
dementia unfortunately there's no cure
for the condition Gary Oldman is another
high-profile actor to show up in the
Fifth Element having already knocked it
out of the park in the likes of Bram
Stoker's Dracula JFK and Immortal
Beloved a few years earlier additionally
Old Men played the big bad and Leon the
Professional so director Luke pasand
probably didn't have to work too hard to
get him onto the project he plays Jean
baptiste's Emanuel Zork the secondary
antagonist responsible for all the
action that plays out on screen though
he shares only a little screen time with
the heroes what's wrong with me since
wrapping The Fifth Element oldman's work
has been a master class inactic he found
his way onto several tent bull
franchises including a turn as James
Gordon in the Dark Knight trilogy on top
of that he played Sirius Black in the
Harry Potter franchise and Dreyfus in
Dawn of the Planet of the Apes but old
men didn't just deal in franchises his
most celebrated work has been in
Prestige dramas that have earned him
most of his impressive accolades for his
work in 2011's Tinker Taylor Soldier Spy
he was nominated for the Academy Award
for best actor in a leading role in in
2018 he took home the Oscar for his
portrayal of Winston Churchill in
darkest hour and in 2021 he was
nominated once more for his work in Bank
in 2022 he jumped to television to play
the leading role in Apple TV's slow
horses and he portrayed President Harry
S Truman and Christopher Nolan's
Oppenheimer so the man has certainly
been busy Syrian home's impressive
career began in the late 50s and he
spent the next six decades racking up
one outstanding credit after another of
his many excellent performances
throughout the 20th century some
standouts include playing Ash and alien
and Sam musabini in Chariots of Fire of
course it was the stage that started his
career in Holmes Shakespearean work in
the theater and later on film
distinguished him as one of the most
talented actors of his generation home
played priest Vito Cornelius in The
Fifth Element and he has a prominent
role throughout thanks
for absolutely nothing he Hatches the
plan to get lilu out to find the stones
which intersects with the president's
scheme to use Corbin Dallas to the same
end Holm had more statues on his mantle
than his co-stars when he came onto the
film so he added plenty of Gravitas to
the production when his time working on
The Fifth Element came to an end Holm
appeared in dozens of high-profile films
most notably homeless cast to play Bilbo
Baggins in The Lord of the Rings trilogy
my precious
precious he returned to play the
character twice more in The Hobbit and
Unexpected Journey and its second sequel
the Battle of the Five Armies sadly that
was his final film role as Holm died in
June 2020 at the age of 88. his health
had been in Decline since 2001. due to
about with prostate cancer followed by a
diagnosis of Parkinson's disease most
movie fans know Mila Jovovich these days
but that wasn't necessarily true before
the fifth element before joining the
cast her two most notable roles were
playing Mildred Harris and chaplain and
Michelle Burroughs in Dazed and Confused
it was her role as Lilo in the fifth
element that elevated Jovovich to super
stardom
in the film she plays the titular being
The Fifth Element capable of defeating
evil in its purest form she's also the
love interest of Corbin Dallas and an
impressive fighter to boot laylu showed
jovovich's potential as an action movie
star before long she was cast as the
lead in bassan's next project the
messenger the story of Joan of Arc while
that movie didn't turn many heads
jovovich's most prominent casting came a
few years later in 2002's Resident Evil
the video game franchise kept Jovovich
employed through six films from 2002
until 2016. Jovovich didn't stick with
working in a single franchise booking
jobs in nearly 30 Films over the course
of two decades she played Vivian nimue
the blood Queen in the 2019 Hellboy
reboot and took the late in 2020's
Monster Hunter while it's easy to see
how Jovovich has kept herself gainfully
employed in the decades following The
Fifth Element it's difficult to imagine
what her career would look like had she
not been cast as Lilo in the 1997
classic Chris Tucker's career began on
the small screen but he didn't stay
there for long after appearing in an
episode of Hanging with Mr Cooper and
two appearances on Def Comedy Jam Tucker
started Landing small parts and films in
the early 1990s Tucker's breakout role
was Smokey and Friday which inspired
more than a few memes
he then played Skip in Dead Presidents
but his performance as Ruby rod and The
Fifth Element made Tucker a household
name Ruby Rod is such an outlandish
character the true peacock of the
picture so tell me my man
[Music]
uh not really it's impossible to
overlook and while he plays the comic
relief to straight man Corbin Dallas
he's so much more than that throughout
the entire film Ruby Rod keeps his radio
show going only choosing to sign off
when the action dies down Tucker's
brilliant take on the character makes
excellent use of the actress Charisma
and as a result Ruby Rod is arguably one
of the best parts of the film after The
Fifth Element Tucker landed the role of
James Carter opposite Jackie Chan in the
rush hour Trilogy a franchise that
quickly became one of the best buddy cop
series of the century Tucker returned to
stand up in 2011 and spent much of his
time in that Arena making sporadic film
appearances he's also known as a
humanitarian and philanthropist Luke
Perry's acting career began in
television and that's where he made his
Mark while he appeared in movies
throughout the 1990s he became a
household name playing Dylan McKay in
Beverly Hills 90210 that role made Barry
a star and it opened a lot of doors for
the actor he had a lead role in the 1992
film Buffy the Vampire Slayer and landed
numerous roles voicing animated
characters including Sub-Zero and Mortal
Kombat Defenders of the realm and Jones
and the Incredible Hulk while he only
had a small role as Billy in The Fifth
Element Harry's performance is heartfelt
and demonstrative of his talent he
assists the professor as he uncovers the
truth of The Fifth Element and as a
run-in with Amanda shawans who kill his
mentor after the intro Billy's
contribution to the film is over so
Perry had plenty of time to keep working
he landed dozens of roles in movies and
television throughout the late 90s in
the 2000s after The Fifth Element Perry
played the titular lead in Jeremiah and
Fred Andrews in Riverdale who he played
for over 45 episodes his final role was
Wayne monder and Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood sadly the film was released
posthumously as Perry had a massive
stroke in February 2019. after a second
stroke soon after his family made the
difficult move to remove Perry from life
support he died on March 4th 2019 at the
age of 52. for most of his career Ryan
James was one of those actors you always
recognize but never exactly remembered
who he was that's because the man was a
brilliant character actor who threw
everything into each role James career
began in the early 1970s when he landed
roles in several television shows in
feature films Angie went on to act
alongside many of the greats as the
years went on his most prominent film
role before the fifth element was
arguably Leon Kowalski and Blade Runner
the replicant who fails the void comp
tests at the beginning of the film let
me tell you about my mother
after that he continued playing
interesting characters you've likely
seen in dozens of movies but he was
never particularly memorable as those
weren't the type of roles James usually
took this changed a bit when he was cast
to play General Monroe in The Fifth
Element the role is prominent but also
somewhat brief still he's commanding as
the man in charge making this yet
another of his incredible performances
after The Fifth Element James kept
himself busy by continuing to appear in
multiple movies every year in fact James
worked so much he had several films
released posthumously James had a heart
attack on August 7 1999 at the age of
54. he had an impressive career with
nearly 180 roles to his name at the time
of his death additionally James voiced
numerous animated characters throughout
his career Tommy Tiny Lister Jr spent
much of his career making money off his
impressive size and scope of talent he
is probably best known for his role as
Debo the neighborhood Thug from Friday
though he'd been acting steadily for
over a decade before landing that role
Lister often played bad guys taking
advantage of his impose losing stature
Not only was he tall at six feet five
inches but he was muscular and had a
massive frame the man was an
intimidating figure when he wanted to be
Lister was also a professional wrestler
having joined the WWF in 1989 so he
definitely took advantage of his size
throughout his career when he was cast
as president Lindbergh in The Fifth
Element it was a different type of role
for the actor he never had trouble
playing an authority figure but most of
his parts were more enforcer types than
political leaders he plays the character
with a sort of diplomatic intimidation
that never separates him from his acting
Roots making Lindbergh one of his most
memorable characters better do you hear
me
get out of there Lister continued
working steadily for decades after
filming wrapped on the fifth element
while he had numerous roles many were in
shorts or direct to video films
listener's Health began to decline in
his 50s and he had a bad case of kova 19
in 2020. he recovered but was found dead
in his home on December 10th 2020. while
covid-19 was suspected lister's official
cause of death was heart disease John
bluethal began acting in the late 1950s
working primarily on television until
Landing his first film role in 1963.
still television is where he blossomed
Landing popular roles on home sweet home
the Vicar of Dibley and Milligan Inn
luthal had primarily minor roles in film
playing a blind beggar in the return of
the Pink Panther and Avenger in Superman
3. despite having small parts he
appeared in many high-profile movies
throughout the 1970s and 80s by the time
bluethal was cast as professor patcholi
in The Fifth Element he was nearing the
end of his impressive six decade career
like Luke Perry the false part is brief
but memorable Aziz lights
is
when he finished filming his part for
The Fifth Element bluefall's career
somewhat slowed down this was likely
more due to his age than anything else
but he appeared in fewer films and
television series during this time his
most prominent roles after The Fifth
Element came from playing another
professor in hail Caesar and Uncle to
see him in Jungle which was his final
full-length film credit luthal died on
November 15 2018 at the age of 89. his
family revealed that his death came
following complications from a fall and
he died peacefully in the hospital
surrounded by his family my when labesco
began working as a child notably playing
Ellen one deadly Summer she continued
acting for Years first working with her
then husband Luke bassan and Leon the
Professional where she had a minor role
her next project was also with the sun
playing Diva plava Laguna in the fifth
element in the film Diva plavalaguna's
performance comes to a chaotic end when
a fight breaks out mortally wounding her
she tells Corbin Dallas that she has the
stones inside her and after he retrieves
them she dies leibesco hasn't been
confined to just acting she's also
worked as a director screenwriter and
producer as her career progressed she
leaned more heavily into directing
having received much of a claim for her
2011 film police which won the coveted
jury prize that can that year levesco
has also worked in comedy creating a
one-woman show detailing her life in the
entertainment industry her experiences
of getting into acting at an early age
meeting her future husband when she was
12 and the beginning of the relationship
three years later clearly influenced her
work her latest directing effort paired
Levesque with Johnny Depp and John
Dewberry with death taking on the role
of Louis XV the best goat continues to
act in films including her own John
Neville found his way into acting via
the theater where he appeared in just
about every production of a Shakespeare
play performed throughout the 1950s and
60s in London he switched gears and
moved to Canada in 1972 where he
continued performing in Theatrical
Productions Neville also worked in film
television and TV movies any accumulated
dozens of minor roles throughout the
course of his career as far as Neville's
film work goes he's arguably best known
for playing the lead in Terry gilliams
the adventurers of Baron Munchausen
with reinforcements don't lose heart
while he continued working in TV in film
his next noteworthy role didn't come
until 1997's the fifth element in the
movie Neville plays General Shredder the
commander who first encounters the
ultimate Evil in space he fires
everything he can at it before
succumbing to its influence resulting in
the destruction of his ship devil
remained busy after filming his role in
The Fifth Element though he continued to
appear in minor Parts as he got older
Neville's workload declined Nas did his
health he was diagnosed with Alzheimer's
disease and eventually died surrounded
by his family on November 19 2011 at the
age of 86. while Neville's cause of
death wasn't made public it was likely
the result of complications from
Alzheimer's disease which often causes
aspiration pneumonia Charlie Creed miles
started acting on television in the late
1980s and it didn't take long for him to
add film roles to his repertoire
throughout the 80s and early 1990s he
had several prominent roles in
television appearing as Dany and press
gang and Al in the upper hand around
this time he also played notable roles
and let him have it in the punk in 1997
he landed the role of David in The Fifth
Element and his performance is both
funny and relatable he's a kid thrust
into responsibility he continuously
insists he's not ready to meet
fortunately he's wrong for the most part
and manages to carry the story along
through his ineptitude and Devotion to
duty The Fifth Element was one of many
significant film roles Creed miles
landed throughout his career and he's
been working steadily ever since after
The Fifth Element he had a standout
performance and Gary oldman's critically
acclaimed writing and directorial debut
nil by mouth which he followed with
Essex boys Harry Brown and Wild Bill
Creed miles continued working in
television throughout his career mostly
showing up in small parts and projects
like peaky blinders and giri Lee
Evans was already a well-established
stand-up comic by the time he found his
way to the set of The Fifth Element
Evans comedy took him all over as native
UK and he built up quite a reputation
for his energetic and witty performances
while he's a comic at heart Evans has
dabbled in just about every aspect of
the entertainment industry he appeared
in his first movie in 1995 as Jack
Parker and funny bones and his next
movie Project was The Fifth Element two
years later in the film Evans plays fog
the only one left in charge aboard the
yacht when the aliens attack he happily
seeds control to Corbin Dallas and
stands by doing the best he can it's a
minor role to be sure but memorable
nonetheless after The Fifth Element
Evans showed up in Mouse hunt and had a
key role and There's Something About
Mary the following year
I love Mary man he continued working in
television as well appearing in an
episode of Doctor Who another notable
series Evan's transitioned to theater
and appeared in numerous Productions
throughout his career working primarily
as a director and choreographer in 2014
Evans retired from touring following the
sudden death of his manager from a heart
attack he devoted most of his time to
his family and only returned to theater
a few years later for a fundraiser
nowadays he's mostly unretired spending
his days directing theatrical
Productions all over the world tricky's
entry into the entertainment industry
began in the mid-1980s Via hip-hop he
picked up the name Tricky Kid when he
was 18 and belonged to several groups
including the renowned trip hop band
Massive Attack of which he was a
founding member in the 1990s tricky had
a solo breakthrough with his debut album
Max and Quay which propelled him to
International stardom throughout this
time tricky appeared in numerous music
videos but didn't get into acting until
Luke bassan cast him his right arm in
the fifth element in the film right arm
is well he's the right arm of Zork and
he does everything the man asks of of
him he fires 1 million cab drivers when
only half are needed and he attempts to
board the same yacht as Corbin Dallas
but fails this earns him an immediate
termination from Zork who detonates a
bomb killing him tricky's acting career
has been sporadic since the Fifth
Element he's appeared in four episodes
of girlfriends and that's pretty much it
aside from an uncredited role as senior
Monk and Ghost in the Shell in 2017. of
course acting was never tricky's primary
interest and despite giving a memorable
performance his right arm he's a
musician at heart since the film
premiered tricky has continued to record
albums he's toured the world performing
and is considered a pioneer of hip-hop
as his career progressed tricky became a
record producer and remains an important
figure in the hip-hop community
foreign